you heard about this little new Little
Mermaid the Ariel she's gonna be a black
girl we spoke about that while ago okay
basically if you aren't aware Ariel
Little Mermaid the live action they're
gonna have uh what was it Chloe Chloe
Berry what's her name okay it doesn't
matter she's a young black woman very
good singer talented cool she's gonna be
Ariel it's no longer be a white redhead
so so somebody posted this online I
thought it was very interesting
artificial intelligence scientist all
right has decided to fix a Little
Mermaid and turn the woke actor into a
ginger white girl basically going from
Chloe to a white girl with red hair
he says he can do the fix for the whole
movie when it comes out
in 24 hours and then afterwards he posts
like an image look what he did you see
this
from this to this
this is using artificial intelligence
and like just okay well why do they do
that
because a lot of people are mad that
Ariel is now going to be a black woman
okay they want it to stay away and then
he says for Twitter this purely for
educational purposes please do not
misinterpret this in a racist way I'm
just amazed by high IQ friend who works
with artificial intelligence and the
stuff you can make I want to show people
his field of study okay so there's two
parts
okay there's a first part which is the
change is it racist and the second part
which is our thoughts about the whole
aerial changing which we kind of touched
on first so okay I don't think you can
really separate the two someone told me
this recently I never really thought
about it but a bunch of Gingers were
hitting me up like bruh we don't get
represented enough is that what you're
talking about it's like ginger is
represented on TV and movies is not a
thing so Ariel was like the one person
that we had
you disagree I I'm thinking okay
and look
I rack on gingers you guys know me
there's no beautiful Ginger people out
there yada yada okay I was speaking of
which remember I said there's no
beautiful Ginger people out there
well it's a bunch of Gingers disagreed
of course they send you nudes and all
they did was reinforce my opinion
send your pictures
no I looked at their pictures they had
profile I was like yeah I agree with
what I said and this guy had a video on
us I am disheartened angry and quite
frankly disappointed this morning I
logged into youtube.com and decided to
watch a video by my favorite comfort
creators Abba and preach and in that
video Abba said this I'm gonna go with
contestant three I don't really know my
reason I just think number three first
I would I would have kept the
there are no beautiful Ginger people
that's the best troll ever he's trolling
there are no beautiful Ginger people
those words they tore my heart in half
shout outs to you my dude that's funny
as [ __ ] that was funny as hell it was as
a mediocre average person looks like
we're like this doesn't work it's okay
all you gingers come on get a big group
hug at least I think you have a soul
which is all that really matters because
Jesus will give you salvation as a
born-again Christian that's all I care
about not how ugly you are on the
outside but how beautiful you can be on
the inside that's it so so
they were telling me about Ginger
representation and it is an interesting
thing and my stance on this is the same
one I had when we talked about this
three years ago which is I'm not mad at
the idea of representation I'm not mad
at the idea that it's kind of cool to
have Disney characters of all Races
walks of life I just don't like it when
it's forced and I think it's kind of
corny to take fairy tales with One race
and then just switch them when they have
such a historic Circle but like there's
already a History built with the fans
and the viewers and how they view it
it's the same way like if I read Harry
Potter and Harry Potter's always been
described as a white dude with freckles
and a [ __ ] scar on his face and all
this stuff and you changed the race for
the live adaptation imma look at you
funny that's it I prefer it if you want
to create this whole idea of
representation to just create stories
that have black bases as characters
right nobody got mad when they looked at
the Black Panther stuff and they saw
nothing about black folks nobody got mad
when they did a bunch of other
live-action movies and had black people
as leads because that's how the stories
were originally written and it doesn't
have to be stereotypically black either
they could be characters who happen to
be black and it's not because like they
speak with ebonics or whatever they can
just be regular too so I'm not against
that
I just don't like the retelling of old
stories with like race swaps or gender
swaps it's like same thing with like
superheroes all of a sudden changing
genders I find that [ __ ] kind of corny
enforced so my preference people don't
like that either
most people don't like that my
preference is tell great stories Court
stories that have always been black and
that always if that was at the center of
it and and show that to the Young
Generation so that they can see
themselves and I'm all for that you know
what I'm saying
um
but yeah I don't know it's maybe because
of the time we grew up in we had Fresh
Prince we had the Jamie Foxx Show we had
the Bill Cosby Show we had such an array
of different accents and ways of talking
and moving that I got to see a little
bit of ourselves representing a lot of
media in that regard so some degree to
some degree
I wouldn't have liked it if they redid
friends and stuck a black bunch of black
people exactly that would have been
coordinated that it would have been
corny if they did they did that to
anything like Full House was Full House
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air was Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air and Full House was really
quite all white people you know I don't
want to see I saw Full House I don't
want to see a house full of [ __ ]
that was fine bro
that was foul
that was the hell
thank you
Uncle Ruckus Rose from the grave for
that [ __ ] I just want to see original
wait a lot no house full of [ __ ] over
there I want to see I want to see
Original Stories I don't want to see a
black James Bond I saw the heart of the
fall or the harder they fall with lucky
Stanfield made by the movie was made by
the bullets it's still on Netflix I
thought that [ __ ] was
dope it was about Cowboys right it was
Cowboys it was a black cast it was good
people and bad people both black and it
was an original story I really do think
that the point that the gingers made to
me about Ginger representation was facts
it was facts yeah like I I never thought
about it because you don't really think
about Ginger people as being like
different yeah uh but they are they are
Ariel and they add that princess from
Brave that's what they had what's brave
brave is a princess exactly what's Brave
hey we don't watch movies like that
anyway they probably don't know it
either a lot of these people don't know
it
you think about it if like genders feel
that different for them this was their
thing and they got erased I can
understand that was a fact and so I can
understand that but that's what I'm
saying I'll say this do I believe that
the scientists did this because he felt
like gingers were beat no I don't think
so I think people saw the race Swap and
they got mad so could you see that as
being rich maybe you can certainly make
the case and I wouldn't fight you on it
one way or the other I'm not fighting
but considering the fact that like
ginger representation is a thing and you
guys are just swapping these things I
can understand why some people are
bothered by you can't make the argument
like oh well it's just a fictionist
character why would it matter
and then also say well black people feel
represented obviously it doesn't matter
you can't have it both ways you can't
say it doesn't matter it's your favorite
conviction this character and then also
justify the reason why the re-swap
happened to begin with and also let's
not pretend please just for me and you
let's not pretend that when they did
this casting they didn't set themselves
on we're going to hire a black person
for this specifically obviously they did
and they've been doing this a lot this
is a concerted movement to have a
certain number here's something that you
guys may not know
nowadays when they do sets for shows
this for comedy how about for comedy
they had something called uh they had a
comedy show here I'm not gonna say what
it is they asked me to do it I said no I
don't want to do it this is like on a
big Festival come to find out the lineup
comes and some of my white comic friends
tell me it's like yeah we weren't even
allowed to apply I'm like why they said
because we only wanted one white male
for the whole 10 comic lineup and we
already booked them
everyone else got to hit they quotas
these things do not happen on accident
this is not a meritocracy it's like it's
a miracle autocracy by race
do you understand what I'm saying the
best black profile for this show no no
no
so just know this is something that
people are doing consciously and so that
changes it and the only reason they
would do it consciously is because they
understand what it means it's not just
this arbitrary thing that they're doing
for fun it means something oh you know
hold on I don't want to say that yeah
all right well I don't want to say it's
like it feels whenever they did all the
reboots that they did and they do all
the versions that they do and then after
that they give the role to a black
person we did that we said that already
before Paul was saying again when they
do that it to me to me after that it
feels like crumbs that's what I was
trying to say it feels like crumbs like
we're getting the plate out leftover of
something that was used and abused and
then after that we get our part whereas
whenever you get an original story we
get the full meal
yes I also say this
I don't just feel this way about race I
remember there were specific types of
French movies that were made and then
were brought to America and recasted
with American accents yeah lost all the
um societal context that makes the humor
and the taxis one what was the one with
Kevin Hart and the guy in the wheelchair
well the original one's amazing the
American version was disgusting horrible
but the reason why they make these
casting changes because they think this
is what's going to work with the but
they lose all the Artistry they'd lose
the heart of what the writer did when
they created the whole thing and with
that movie they didn't even change the
game the gender no they didn't change
the race they just changed the car they
just changed the context and they
changed as it lost all right and art is
already a difficult thing to make work
perfectly when you start only thinking
about the commercial aspect let's hire
this actor because they've got a
following on Twitter let's get this
person because they're Tick Tock famous
you're killing the ark you're killing it
right and so when all these [ __ ]
execs are getting involved in these
decision makings and everything is just
about the bottom line and the dollar and
none of it's based off of a skill to
compensate for it I start to look at
them funny I'm gonna be honestly I don't
really like movies as much I definitely
don't like movies as much I used to and
same for TV it's too much of this like
forced [ __ ] to just try to sell
everything let's include a storyline
about race let's include you know what
why don't you just make a story about a
black character who doesn't have to
revolve around the fact that they're
black those are great too you know what
I'm saying I'm not interested in having
all this stuff forced it made me think
of that movie Queen and slim and slim
trash
that movie was a plus garbage bro it
might be the worst movie I've seen the
last decade that's how bad it was
everything was forced everything was
just virtue signal everything was just
like all right this storyline and the
way that white people view black
Americans and the way that blacked me
and like trying to represent something
symbolically rather than real organic
storytelling so this is the kind of
stuff that I'm seeing more and more in
movie where it's just like how can we
hit those political brownie points
rather than telling a really well
developed story so that's my gripe with
it maybe I'll feel differently even this
Marvel Universe and this need to make a
hundred superhero movies a year it's not
because they're telling good stories and
they're trying to tell these authentic
superhero stories well it's because they
make money
they're doing the The Source material
like no justice half the time what do
you mean
what you mean what I mean Megan Italian
I was quirking with uh She-Hulk was not
part of the new movie
I'm not even what do you mean it was not
part of the movie what are we doing
what are we doing what do you mean a
lawyer twerking you've never seen that
but yeah let us know what you guys think
we want to hear from you